31 days in July.
So July has regular days.
31 or like whatever and then there's like sale days.
And you're like, okay, on a sale day or like you can do a weekday.
This is probably more accurate because there is a lot of fluctuation in our business between weekdays and weekends.
Right.
So you can go, okay, there's like this many weekdays in July.
Let me just do it real quick while I'm here.
There's like one, two, three, four, five, 10, 15, 20, 23.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
23 and then we have.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 weekends.
And then we have, let's say, four sale days.
I'm just making this up or two sale days.
We might do a flash sale.
And then you can be like, on an average day, we make 40K.
On a weekend, we do 60K.
And on a sale day, we do 100K.
Just making this up and you can look at like the averages on GA to confirm that, but that's kind of somewhat class probably.
So, and then you've got this equals this times this.
And then you pull your formula down.
And then you've got a total.
Boom bang thing.
Okay.
Would you do this for like July 24 and 25 or like month by month would you go through and do this just to kind of get maybe not but it'll give you more of like a granular insight into how each month performs.
You want to get
to the most accurate of these inputs.
But what I would do is I would triangulate last year, the last three months, you know what I'm saying?
So like the closer in accuracy you get to what these special days look like, the closer your total is going to become.
And so what I would do is
I would do it both ways just because you're learning the business and also there is a lot of fluctuation in the business.
So you kind of want, so if this exercise gets you to two million and this exercise only gets you to 1.6, you're like, okay, what is off here?
If these are within 100K of each other, you're basically at your, you're at a pretty accurate point here.
using two different models to project the numbers and they're close and similar to each other.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah.
You learn and Jordan?
I mean, like visual examples like this help my brain out so much.
Of course.
Yeah.
That's what I'm here for.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Of course.
Okay, so Q3 and then same thing with all the other months, but start with July and just like, you know, use now the logic that I know you have, which is like, all right, paid social.
If we're like, oh man, we really like, that's shitting the bed right now, meta, like, I'm not going to rely that heavily on it.
Or man, I actually think if we invest, we can get this amount of traffic.
And then you may also want to put into here like a spend.
assumption.
Yeah.
So if you're like, okay, spend on actually not to make this even more complicated, but you know, that's what we do sometimes, spend low end.
And then you want to go spend high end.
Where are you feeling?
Yep.
So you may end up having different.
Whoops.
And with 2024, because that data is already there, it's probably easier to
Like we put them actually, it can be actualized for 2024.
And what, 2025, we would do the high end low end fragile.
That's right.
Cool.
Yeah.
And you'll actually, in that case, you would have two traffic on the high and the low.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Right.
So traffic.
Hi.
And then traffic.
Oh, I know.
I realized I'm doing this on the other Y tab.
That's confusing.
So I'll just change these.
See what I did there.
Yeah.
Oops.
This is making sense.
Yeah, no, definitely.
Cool.
Okay, so hit it with this and then definitely clean up some of your assumptions on the year.
Okay.
I am going to actually just make a new version of my master because it's getting messy and I don't want that many people in it.
So
Let me get that real quick.
I think messy, messy, messy.
My file make coffee.
Share, shareable.
And the one you want me working on is the existing one or the new one?
A new one.
OK, cool.
Do you want me to revert changes on the existing one?
No, that's OK.
I'm down once we're here with you.
Cool.
Because here's what'll happen is like, if you're in the middle of workshopping, but being Chris are looking at it for other reasons, he's going to be like, you're July target, or Sharma's going to be like, you're going to be good, and I'm like, no.
So, okay, let me give you access to this one.
All right, now you have the shareable one.
Let me know if you're in it.
Not shareable, maybe shareable is a bad way of team.
sheet.
Okay, now you're in it.
Good.
So then.
Yeah, mess with these summaries first and then we can go into.
It's like we definitely ought to build in some of that growth here.
And you also have to remember our spend in July and August on non-lower funnel activity.
So like the testing that we want to do on YouTube, on mountain, on like all those things, that needs to happen in July, August, September and Q3 so that we lock in
that juice.
Okay.
And the mountain mountain is like 10k is what we could get away with like 15 was the the you get a wrap 10k was just like recommended starting by the game.
Great.
10.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me just make some notes for myself to consider those things.
Yeah.
So that's what I think we should do that on a separate slide here.
So actually know what I'm going to clean some of this up.
look or spend, you don't need any of that.
I'm gonna delete the side because you don't need it.
And then the side of it.
I do think that in these individual pages, so like, okay, wait, shoot, I'm not sharing my screen.
I'm in the worksheet and then I'm in the month, right?
on these guys, we should have more detailed breakout here and what we're doing.
So for example, I just put these numbers in.
for like demand gen.
And when I'm saying demand gen maybe that's confusing and we can name it whenever we want together.
But this is like a one to one investment.
Like I'm not giving it the same row as goal as these guys.
And that's just meant to be our like awareness and top of funnel stuff.
And even one to one is like high expectations for that type of thing.
So am I best understanding Demand Jenna just made like the new way to run YouTube?
Yeah.
Well, that's why I want to rename it.
Because all I'm saying here is like top of funnel.
Yeah.
OK.
Google top of all.
Well, no, it doesn't have to be limited to it.
So like, okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, now I see where the confusion is coming.
Yeah, yeah, we should definitely not.
Like everything.
Yeah, yeah, it's more criminal as a strategy.
Yeah, Google could include mountain could include all this other.
Yeah, yeah, I get you, I get you, I get you, I get you.
Yeah, yeah, let's do it because I'm I'm specifically thinking demand in campaigns.
Product type in Google when that when that comes to mind.
So that's helpful.
I'm glad you pointed that out because I would have gone more days without recognizing that word exactly.
So I think that.
This is maybe where we we for like our level of oversight and simplicity.
I think we keep it to these three.
But then Sharma.
And you together need to have way more detail, right?
So like under this paid social, there's probably like four things.
There's like meta, there's like, there's even like, what are we doing in reals versus like all of those things is like, there's like more here.
But for the sake of this document, I only care that paid social is this and this.
Yeah.
I mean, when it comes to those channels, it's going to vary either way.
Based on performance, some things may not worked out.
And we're going to kind of like pinch this, right?
Like we may have allocated X amount of dollars to pinch this, but that's going to get rotated and changed if it's all worked out.
Yeah.
So that that level of detail needs to be captured.
I don't need it captured here.
Gotcha.
So all I care about is that the line item of paid social.
This is how much we're spending.
This is how much we're getting.
This is the efficiency in the channel.
Where is like you and Sharma should know all of the different variables and like channels and activities that ladder up to paid social.
Okay.
Yeah, no, for sure.
I definitely considered it more in the weeds than it comes like the tactical, like, hey, what are we optimizing towards on these channels?
Obviously, we have overall goals, but it's just like, how can we get to those overall goals by making sure we use the right products on these channels?
So that's that's your job and charm is right.
My job is to be like Jordan and Sharma you have a hundred thousand dollars for this channel and I expect this how this much out of it and you need to know based on the the performance and the like you know lately we've done that it out like you can be like ingrid that is totally accomplishable or ingrid you are smoking crack here's what I think this channel should actually be
Yeah, the July efficiency is like my only concern because we don't have like we've got the fourth of July but we're not doing the sale and then we don't have the product push.
So that's why I'm in where in July.
So that's the only thing that makes me nervous is like that five, seven top line because we just came off a five month.
But I think workshopping through this will give me more confidence around or clarity when I was possible.
So that's where I'm saying it's like, tell me.
And again, like within the month, you can shift.
I don't care.
How does that efficiency is the efficiency, right?
So getting on top of Google, I was like, man, there's like, there's efficiency and some top line that we can capture.
Let's lean into that, right?
So you're not married to these allocations and I think you know that but that's where like the other document that we just created is going to help you right because you're going to be like okay we were we were forecasting that.
this that like social is going to give us this traffic and this conversion rate and this amount of sales, right?
And actually, it's tracking that we're getting this amount of, you know, sales from that.
And so we need, we need to change that.
Or you could be like, all right, that first week, if we were going to do at this pace, then we're behind or we're ahead and did it out.
So like once you have this, you can then workshop into like what in the,
Basically, what's being broken and how do we need to reallocate resources?
Yeah, that's clear to me.
And just based off of like gut feeling with Google is like, with the push up, I hope it maintain like the cactus and blow out too high to where throws are blended off.
I mean, anything lower than Facebook and spending more is going to be good overall.
But yeah, that's just where like, I know we're scaling Google.
We've got to wait two weeks before we can really determine if it's successful or not, but that's like,
another week into the month.
And if we're going to push hard on Google, we probably need to be scaling more.
So yeah, we're shopping through this is definitely going to help get more clarity there.
But just knowing off of how this stuff works, that's where my concern is at.
And I'm like, OK, Google looks good, but I know we probably need to be pushing harder if we're going to hit our goals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's where like, you know, this isn't like a set and forget it.
That's why there's humans that need to manage this stuff.
But yeah, I think, and again, if we're like dropping some efficiency here and there, like, you got to just let me know.
And then I can pull other lovers.
Word.
Okay.
And then if you're like, look, the main thing is the top line with the, with the, with the spend goal.
If one of these needs to go, you let me know the worst case scenario is
that we drop in our efficiency.
What is the lowest efficiency, because looking at Q2, everything's been about four.
You guys are really, really efficient.
What is low considered low in the eyes of the business?
And four is low.
Yeah, that's crazy.
I mean, we've run a tight ship around here, Jordan.
Yeah, because I, yeah, no, I've seen Breadskill hard at like two, but I know like the economics are different.
So that's when I'm also wrapping my head around because you guys have such a huge AOV, but I also know it costs more to manufacture the types of products you sell.
So the margins are like, the economics might be a little bit different than what I'm used to.
But yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm going to say I'm going to say a four.
It's like, that's the floor.
That's, that's impressive.
I know, man.
We've got a tight ship around here.
Yeah.
Do not, do not, do not, do not.
Um, even, okay, appetite for like volume.
I'll say you guys start to say, I mean, January, Q1, there's a million in spend.
What was that efficiency at?
Let me do that real quick.
I'm curious like what is it look?
Yeah, I came down to three five two.
Yeah, I was back.
Yeah.
Hey.
Okay.
Cool.
There's other stuff for you, Jordan, right?
It's like, we're doing more sampling and more affiliate.
We're doing more, but we look at those historicals, man.
Yeah, no, it's in probably like, it's like 2023 is a six.
I mean, obviously it wasn't a million in spin.
24 is a five on 600, so adding another 400 shouldn't have realistically brought it down that much for your changes, advertising platform gets more expensive, more software, each other.
In January?
That's the old agency fired in March.
Okay, 352385.
So then they were struggling for three months.
And when did they join on with higher dose, like the prior, prior, you're like, well, 2024, what month's within energy?
I guess this is what I'm trying to ask.
I'm sorry, full time in January.
I only gave him three months.
They got you day.
Yeah.
They came out to get swinging on a million and spend that's insane.
Yeah Wow, because yeah, you guys were not pushing that hard in the month leaving up prior.
I mean, okay.
I see December 2.9 November 1.3, but yeah, but that's what you're expecting to do in January.
We do have a pretty big pullback because I was looking at that.
I was like, why was a million spending key want like January?
Like is it?
Usually, like most of the brands I've worked with in the beauty space, they've got a pretty big pullback in January.
I know you guys have more health and wellness, but like these products do lean into beauty as well.
But yeah, it's interesting.
But New Year and New Me, so maybe that's where they thought they'd be able to continue that volume.
Yeah, because even like the spin to sales, you're basically your media, your murder percentages has been fairly low across the board.
Like, you know, 20% is like high for you guys.
So like over 20, 20 plus is.
Yeah, our goal is like a 22.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
That's where the, the, like, this year.
So like, this is where, okay, so now let's like come to Jesus here.
This thing, this is what I live and die by.
We have to get to, like, and I will tell you right now, if we get to here, you will get a fat ass bonus for me.
Okay.
Like,
that ask bonus, like, fucking 20%.
It is worth your focus.
I will make sure you are paid.
We can do it.
That's the whole thing.
I have no doubt.
We also, you got to remember, there's a couple of things that are working in our favor.
So just talk about the tailwinds, I get that.
Here are your headwinds.
Here are your tailwinds.
We're launching two more products before the end of the year.
Beautiful.
It's like a medium product.
It's not going to do what the body sculptor did, which is the red light wrap.
The other one is the shower head.
Oh, yeah, you got it.
Yeah, you got to shoot an October.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, shower heads are gonna crush.
Definitely need founder videos.
I'll tell you that just from experience and run.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Found a like creative is going to.
And Lauren, you're not gonna get a better founder-led video than Lauren.
Lauren's like smoking hot, so smart, so good at like talking to camera.
She's perfect.
So you'll get those.
And again, that's where so now you're starting to see all the puzzle pieces together.
That's where those briefs that you're working on with Laura are really important because like if it doesn't have a brief, it's not getting created.
Yes, and her and I spoke yesterday Around just brief some like the direction we want to go and getting Sharma more aligned like hey, here's the core products you guys need to be hitting on like routinely because Sharma's kind of not like necessarily shooting in the dark with creative, but it's a bit sporadic So we just there's definitely probably four products We need to focus on that are driving great LTV numbers and we need some more consumption that like obviously the son of like it needs to be innovated on that performance is dropping but
Yeah, we've got a few ideas working in that direction, and then we even spoke on just the inference on itself, because that's high-tech opportunity.
Different approach to marketing that, but could help out a lot, too.
Exactly, exactly.
So Laura is my right hand.
I trust her with everything.
I think I already told you this.
Make sure that you guys are like combining your powers because between the two of you, this is like the power center.
So definitely work closely with Laura.
The other piece is, I don't have any insight into this.
So I have to rely on you.
Where are we with the meta campaigns being restructured to be at the item level?
I don't think they've taken any direct action on doing that.
I need you to be a pit bull with them.
Okay, okay.
I'm like, get it, actually switch the campaign last week.
They relaunched a double campaign, and I think that's a line, but largely it counts still segmented out.
No.
But yeah, I'll be more like,
Because I've been on the other side, and I've taken too much of a passive role, just not telling them exactly what to do, but there's a few things that I want to see change, that I'm trying to influence about, just like, hey, do this, do that, do this.
But I'll be more directive around, hey, we need to be doing this in your own account.
Please make these changes, and just telling them what I want to see so that we can get things switched around a little bit faster.
You are here to do that.
I would say all of that is expected of you.
It's a approach that is important, right?
So like don't go in there and seem roll the shit out of them.
Go in there and have a good conversation with our boy, Jay.
He's a sweetie pie pumpkin.
Like he's not going to like the ego test to go with you or anything like that.
If you're, if like, you have that conversation with him of where you're like, I really want to like, for me, this is me talking, not me impersonating you.
Ingrid wants all of our campaigns to be structured at the product level.
Period.
What's our path to getting there?
How do we do that with the least disruption to our current setup?
And guess what?
If we need to swallow a week of disruption where we toss everything into learning, I'm okay with that.
But just like, help me what that risk is and how long we need to grin and bear it.
And then if you have other stuff like minor optimization stuff that you've been holding back, have that conversation with Jake, give him your logic, have him share his logic with you, and then you're both going to come into a better realization together.
Okay.
Cool.
Like we're still working together versus just telling him, like I want to play at the seed, give him the ability to come up with the ideas of how we navigate there.
So he doesn't feel just from like meet from a media buyer perspective on how I go.
So I also know how to approach it.
So I'll go ahead and get a reach out to him.
And we'll get him.
At the end of the day, if we aren't doing this in this way, I'm going to hold you accountable, not Charmo.
because you were the higher dose employee.
Yes.
Thank you.
What else?
Really, that wasn't my camera this whole time.
I was just yelling hi.
My hair.
How do you enjoy the red light?
Honestly, I'd assume that was just a regular hat that you were wearing, but it is like the hard-dose red light hat, right?
Oh, yeah, I use it all the time.
It's so great.
It works.
I lost so much hair after I had my second kid.
Is that a normal thing?
Yeah.
your hormones going like crazy and all sorts of fun stuff happens.
Yeah, what you guys go through so much to continue this game we call life.
Yeah, you sacrifice a lot.
So my hat goes off to you for doing that and signing up to reproduce because that is a big commitment.
What's also like what we're here to do.
I agree.
I love it.
I love being a mom.
It's really fun.
Um, they're so great.
The boys are like amazing.
And I have a very nice two boys.
Yeah.
That's uh, boys are out here.
So.
Yeah, no for sure chaotic chaotic my mom had like she only has us so I've got a brother that's older But now that I've gotten older and I have a lot of my friends have kids and I see how their boys are and just like dude like there's no way like my parents dealt with that No way because it is absolutely insane jumping off the things fighting all the time ran bunches just high energy and
versus girls girls are like really chill like they may just be dramatic with each other but there's not the high energy always needing to fight something like oh that just never happens i know my house is covered in trucks and balls and like that's my interior decor now and they just like chase each other around thank god they have now each other to do that but they just chase each other around the dining room table
with the trucks and then I like go to my best friend's place that has a girl and the girl like she says, she's just like, what do you like to join me at my teeth party?
Just like has like a tape tape, like a table set, how can I play?
Completely different energy.
My boys are like jumping on her, like the second she comes up with and it's happening her and like her little girl's like, would you like to have a team party and break my hair?
No, probably all good things like just being a parent in general is probably like a great feeling.
I don't know.
I mean, maybe I still got a few more years left before it's like probably too late, but we'll see.
We'll see.
You're a guy.
You don't even have like, I know I could be like 60 from what they said, but I don't want you running to risk the all you get.
And I don't know like,
I'm already, I already feel old, so I feel like getting to waiting even longer.
Like I think in like the 10 or 5 to 10 years, like when kids are like running around and doing all the activities, I'm gonna be exhausted.
Like I'm already tired now, like from not having many responsibilities so I can imagine running around chasing kids all day is gonna be very physically demanding and the older I get, the less likely my body's gonna wanna support that, so.
I don't know, like it's...
I definitely have some like when I was in my early 20s I was just like dang like I don't think I'm ready to have kids yet like I'm gonna wait until I'm 30 not realizing like my body's kind of in a great position to deal with managing children and not like I wake up and like my knees will hard if I sleep the more hard way so
Yeah, I didn't we didn't have kids until much later like I'm 40 so our kids are four and two Okay, I would not have given you that at all.
Definitely.
Yeah, we're very good for each
Thanks.
Yeah, but no, I'm definitely running around and doing all the things, but it's great.
They're great.
You'll find, you find energy reserves in like your soul and your spirit and your heart.
And then there's always like caffeine.
So my friends have said you find a second gear or another gear you know existed.
Yeah, like it just, it's something natural and you kicks in and you just kind of find the willpower to do it.
You know, everything to do.
And it's just like you just know what to do.
It's such a weird concept.
It's true.
Well, I'm around and I'll be online tomorrow.
Are you able to, this was no pressure.
We just thought it would be fun to do like a breathwork session.
I've never done a breathwork, but hopefully you can join.
Yep, I'll be on that one.
I saw that email.
We just got kind of going through maybe what to expect.
I haven't read it, but it seems like a little intro and what to expect for tomorrow's call.
So yeah, I'm curious.
I think it'll be fun.
Cool.
Yeah.
I'm excited.
We'll see then.
I'm dropping up a message to Jake now.
So we'll get that in motion.
And we'll do it.
It's just like early July, you know.
Yeah.
All right.
Cool.
Appreciate you.
Bye.
All right.
Hey.
Honestly, I don't know.
I mean, that should be something I oversee and like paying attention to a lot closer, but I'm just like, eh, I'm not trying to be like, you're talking about ads.
Hey, with agency doing it, that's fine.
Me and other just fucking took over and did that shit like ASA and the Rocky bro, but like, I gotta wait on these niggas to like apply themselves.
Thank you.
I don't know how to do it.
20% of the time.
I can go get 20 bands.